damian lillard standing by with jared
greenberg
damian chris webber just brought up the
point that you made
weeks before we came to the bubble you
said if if you didn't have a chance to
make the playoffs you didn't want to
come
are you glad you're here now yeah i mean
i was
as soon as they told us what the format
was i was glad you know i was more than
happy to come because i have been
preparing to come here since we first
you know got suspended
had a private gym my trainer jim
we got it in i was prepared to come our
team was prepared everybody was in our
gym every day
um once they opened up our facility i
saw everybody there so we was watching
film we was talking
we was together um and i think like i
said before the game
every game we play since we've been here
has been a playoff game so that prepared
us
for a game like this one so it's only
one win
uh like you said i'm happy to be here
and competing in the playoffs again
um and we got to move on to the next one
we all know about game time
we saw it again tonight but but there
appears to be
even a different look in your eyes that
there's something special going on here
in particular when you hit those two
shots from
30 and then 36 feet tonight i mean
i've been saying it for the last two
years uh in the summer
when i step away i find things that you
know can make the game easier for me and
ways that i can improve
and playing from further out was a major
part that i added to my game
and i just think it's starting to show
you know the work is starting to show
and my my trainer phil begner always
tell me you do the work you're going to
get results and i think
um i'm just getting the results reaping
the benefits of the work that i put in
last one we've seen you hit big shots
but we saw you do something that i don't
recall you ever doing before after you
hit the 36 footer we saw some dance
moves right over here in the corner
they played uh they played the east
oakland anthem
so it was only right that i acknowledged
the east oakland anthem and go dumb for
a second
and that was it well congratulations
appreciate forward to seeing you in game
two in a couple days appreciate it
guys highest compliment you can pay a
player
gamer and